he sido toda mi vida un inconforme
siempre empujando a través de la
innovación
llevo 29 años de carrera profesional
la verdad que ha tenido la oportunidad
de trabajar
muy grandes muy interesantes
he desarrollado proyectos y he
construido canales y procesos
y al final siento que no he llegado a
donde pueda donde yo quiero llegar
siento que estoy lejos de donde puedo
llegar
y todo es eso por esa
inconformidad
pero se oye muy feo lo de la
inconformidad pero no es tan feo les
digo por qué
y les pongo un ejemplo
si hoy en la mañana
pero no me alarma y no hubiera levantado
y alguien me ha preguntado segundos años
hoy por qué no te levantaste quizás
hubiera dicho
si no flojera me faltó voluntad
hoy diría
que tuve que no tuve la suficiente
inconformidad
personal para moverme de mi cama hacia
el gimnasio
y eso es la inconformidad cómo puedo
moverme de un punto a un punto de la
inconformidad es la chispa para
aprenderme de ir y moverme
por ahí va el concepto
en mi carrera y la inconformidad me ha
llevado o me ha llevado a dar muchas
cosas
una persona disruptiva me ha llevado a
ser una persona creativa
la inconformidad me ha llevado a hacer
a crear habilidades nuevas me ha llevado
a construir procesos nuevos también me
ha llevado a fracasar
esa misma inconformidad me ha ayudado a
hacer muchas cosas
logros en mi carrera afortunadamente
muchos logros en mi carrera
me ha tocado construir marcas me ha
tocado liderar procesos adquisición de
compañías me ha tocado emprender
negocios nuevos
y construir relaciones comerciales en la
exportación en negocios internacionales
de negocios en mexico
y la verdad ha sido algo padrísimo
la misma campaña de la compañía donde yo
estoy hoy como director de marketing es
una campaña icónica
es una campaña que me ha enseñado
muchísimo tiene 35 años
en el mismo drive creativo
no hay muchas compañías que pueden
y decirlo con ese orgullo 35 años el
mismo drive creativo
y se cuestiona una y otra vez en esta
relación de inconformidad entre una
agencia
y una marca
se cuestiona
y la creatividad
el desempeño de cada día
esa relación de no estoy conforme quiero
hacer lo mejor y quiero hacerlo mejor y
al final dice es que parece el anuncio a
bachoco no
y eso es un ejemplo de un sistema
que ya trabaja en esa inconformidad de
una agencia una marca que entienden muy
bien que lo que tienen que hacer es
hacerlo bien y hacerlo mejor cada día
les platico otra historia
de logro está más en el lado personal
y eso es un poco más reciente
yo tengo tres hijos dos adultos y uno en
proceso
ya llevo varios años diciéndoles
vamos a dejar algo
nunca me hicieron caso
pero el año pasado uno de ellos
a roberto me dijo pues órale
vamos a ver algo de gévora y este que le
picó ahora
dije que quieres hacer mejor no sé
pero más o menos como tanto no sé no sé
qué quiero bien entonces vamos a
vamos a pensar un poco yo te voy a
ayudar a pensar en ejercicio para ver
qué hacemos contigo y cómo puedes crear
algo
y entonces nos fuimos a la base
somos sonorenses de origen sonorense
familias sonorenses nuestra familia está
allá
y los olores son muy buenos para tomar
cerveza sí pero también somos buenos
para echar la carne al asador
y entonces
tenemos en la familia muchos años en el
asador
y roberto ahí estaba como chicle desde
los 6 años pegado en el asador
observando aplicando de repente
habilitado las tortillas
ya tiene algunos años que yo ya me
siento del otro lado de la barra y él me
cocina y entonces eso vamos a hacer eso
entonces empezamos un proceso de
planeación hicimos yo le ayudé a hacer
un análisis de mercado que hacía falta
que veía y un buen día me dijo ya estoy
listo
bueno
el 6 de noviembre del 2020 sale en tick
tock
y en instagram con el nombre de robert
grill
de acero
dijo bueno pues está bien ahora le vamos
a darle no
el día de hoy tres meses y medio después
330 mil seguidores en instagram
y tiene 3.7 millones del cierre sentido
creo que le puse un granito de la
inconformidad se me hace que se me fue
la mano
y a lo mejor el traer otro grano en
conformidad
porque honestamente no tenía necesidad
simplemente fue el vamos a mover esto de
un punto al otro
quizás sea un logro yo creo que sí es un
logro o por lo menos el arranque de una
carrera de el que puede ser una carrera
profesional
y muy interesante
pero no todo es miel sobre ojuelas he
tenido muchos fracasos en mi vida
a lo largo de mi carrera he encontrado
con muchos errores con muchas fallas
he estado en juntas de consejo donde las
cosas no van bien
he tomado decisiones incorrectas
ha perdido dinero con decisiones
incorrectos
el lanzado productos que no hay mercados
he lanzado proyectos que
o ideas que están como llenas de
entusiasmo
sin una base de un modelo de negocios
atrás
me ha tocado ir a japón a pedir perdón
una vez en una compañía que trabaje en
smithfield foods comida muy grande
lanzamos un proyecto de un cerdo que se
llama muy acutal que quiere decir cerdo
sin antibióticos hace muchos años
y de repente nos habla al cliente nos
dice
como problema que pasó pues equivocaron
allí en el alimento es que el problema
ahí voy a
a japon literalmente a pedir disculpas
aprendizaje de los errores aprendizaje
los a casos en este ejemplo la humildad
no son acostumbrados a que cometes un
error
ir a pedir perdón hoy discúlpame eres mi
cliente yo soy tu proveedor
punto
humildad
que otra cosa es para platicar este
un año lanzamos hace algunos años
lanzamos una línea que se llamaba aquí
estados y eran unos unos empaques que
venían producto cocido eran como salsas
eran como productos en sal ensalzados
con sabores mexicanos extraordinarios
yo creo que si ese proyecto mercado
lógicamente lo hubieran mandado a una
universidad no está perfecto está
perfectamente diseñado producto
el empaque el diseño la calidad del
producto el costo el precio del producto
solo nos falló una cosa
adelantamos 10 años
mercado no estaba listo
hicimos lo de estar pensando así que no
es un estudio de mercado claro que sí
mostró de mercado
el mercado no estaba listo
tú puedes tener la mejor idea del mundo
la más innovadora el mejor y si no le
pegas al timing si no es el timing
correcto
no va a funcionar
aprendizaje de ese fracaso el timing
y otra cosa les puedo contar bueno al
principio de mi carrera eso está más en
mi ambiente personal les comparto otro
fracaso muy fuerte creo que el más
fuerte que tiene mi vida cuando eres
tiene gradué me fui a trabajar una
compañía yo estaba muy bien en la
empresa en mis primeros años 23 años tú
en esta empresa está perfecto o sea
estaba tranquilo ganaba bien
pero un ataque en conformidad
quiero aprender de una compañía salvo a
emprender y en aquel entonces hoy ya no
es muy novedoso pero en aquel entonces
fue una pantalla gigante que se dedicaba
a vender comunicación a vender
publicidad apretada de secuestro
salvo al mercado una inversión muy muy
grande y todo iba bien nada más que uno
un problema
lo lanzamos en 1994
recién un poquito de 1924 1.094 él me
dijo fue una catástrofe
un proceso una crisis impresionante este
negocio se fue hice
trono impresionante
aprendizaje
puedes controlar el entorno no puedes
contra el entorno pero que si puedes
hacer después puedes tener escenarios
puedes contemplar esquemas aprendizaje
fracaso aprendizaje siempre fracasé
aprendía algo
y así me puedo ir con muchas historias
de mi vida
para que hace muchas veces
más de las que planean fracasé más veces
de las que quisiste
pero al final siempre encontré esta
línea este hilo de la inconformidad de
acuerdo cuando me quedé sin empleo una
vez me quedo sin empleo
que alves y empleo
sin empleo
no creo que estaba en la casa en la casa
de mis padres
en la sala
que es el lugar más hostil de un lugar
porque ese lugar prende las luces de
navidad y no más entonces era una cosa
terrible
nadie creía en mí yo no creía en nadie
tocas fondo
a una temprana edad no
y ahí fue cuando dije
bendita
porque hoy si yo no me voy a quedar en
este
y no me conformo a mí no me gusta estar
aquí y es ahí donde empiezas a tomar
fuerzas donde empiezas a decir no no
esto no es para mí
y lo voy a levantar
la inconformidad al final
como lo vamos entendiendo
y bueno al final
llegó un poco a la conclusión de decir
si no hay inconformidad
no hay cambio
si no hay cambio no hay innovación
la inconformidad la que nos mueve la que
nos hace movernos
y si ustedes voltean a ver a los grandes
líderes para grandes personalidades más
o menos algunos apellidos a ver si los
ubican así yo pienso en einstein pienso
en luther king
pienso en jordan
jobs
ready para los que les gusta la verdad
ustedes creen que ellos se conforman con
lo que hacen
brady a lo mejor muchos no están famosos
le faltan dedos tap anillo de perfil
conformes gente no se conforman la
inconformidad lo saca te puede sacar de
abajo es me saca de arriba
eso es un barrio que tenemos y eso es
algo que yo
les comparto me ha funcionado en mi
carrera profesional la inconformidad la
innovación y el fracaso
están en la misma vertical
una vertical que va hacia el éxito
la pregunta es
soy la parte más fácil el éxito porque
es porque eso lo definen ustedes
yo defino mi propio éxito nunca dejen
que les define el éxito tú define tu
propio éxito es la falta es la parte más
sencilla de la ecuación lo difícil es
una vez que te pones esa definición a ti
es llegar ahí y para llegar ahí hay que
pasar por esta vertical la vertical pues
es muy compleja al final del día
y la inconformidad no es un objetivo no
no es como la de aquí hay 40 que son
inconformes y los de los demás son
conformes
la economía no funciona así la
inconformidad funciona en ti si tú eres
tú puedes ser muy conforme con tu
carrera profesional y puede ser muy
inconforme con tus estudios o viceversa
o con tus amigos o con quien sea
y la otra cosa que es importante es
la inconformidad lo bonito de esto es
que te ayuda a salir del hoyo pero
también te ayuda cuando llegas a la cima
cuántas empresas no conocen que
estuvieron
en la cima y de repente se fueron por el
barranco muchas aquí en la escuela deben
de ustedes estar hablando de muchos de
esos casos pero al final es la vida la
que nos va
poniendo estas disyuntivas es como un
árbol así me lo imagino un árbol que va
creciendo el tronco y le surgen dos
ramas y entonces salen las dos ramas y
dices
por cual me voy por la gordita o por la
delgadita
por la que quieras oye pero la del
gaditano será quebrar pues si se puede
más riesgoso pues
oye no es más fácil agarrar la gordita
pues sí porque hombre
cada quien va tomando en la vida sus
decisiones que quieres moverte o no
moverte que quieres
pero inconformó quiere ser un conforme
con lo que quiere ser estás conforme con
tu forma de ser estás conforme con tu
cuerpo estás conforme con tus estudios
estás conforme con tus relaciones con tu
pareja estás conforme o no estás
conforme tú decides hacia qué camino
hacia qué rama vas tomando en este
camino de la inconformidad
eso sí le tivo ese camino de la
inconformidad es un camino pedregoso
espinoso
se ponchan las llantas o te puede
explicar
puedes sangrar los pies claro pero saben
que al final cuando llegas es lo más
reconfortante que hay es lo mejor que te
puede pasar te vas a llenarles de una
buena vibra de un gran espíritu
y eso vale todo
al final la vida profesional
entonces está llena de esto la vida
profesional no es fácil para los que
estamos en la vida profesional sabemos
que no es fácil pero tampoco es el
infierno al revés es un lugar padrísimo
donde puedes destacar donde te puedes
cuestionar para retar la vida
profesionales es un lugar donde puedes
crecer conocerte a ti mismo y tener
éxito el éxito que tú quieras
hoy al salir de aquí yo lo que le
recomendaría es
sean innovadores y sean inconformes
mucho